las calles de roma volvieron a quedar
desiertas mientras los italianos se
adaptan a la vida bajo un segundo
confinamiento a nivel nacional
italia había estado sujeta a
restricciones localizadas desde
noviembre pero un aumento de los
contagios provocó nuevas medidas
similares al bloqueo de la primavera
pasada la policía no lo tomó a la ligera
e intensificó los controles de sanción y
manda las multas van desde un mínimo de
400 euros hasta los tres mil euros
incluso rethink o johnny un eventual
paga miento de consentido es cierto que
si se paga en cinco días hay una rebaja
del 30% pero también hay incrementos
para duplicar el mínimo en casos de
repetidas violaciones definitiva en caso
de la interacción e italia no es el
único país europeo en imponer medidas
más estrictas
austria e irlanda volvieron al
confinamiento este sábado uniéndose a
países como eslovaquia lituania y
alemania un nuevo bloqueo que también
entró en vigor en escocia e irlanda del
norte durante el 'boxing day' mientras
que la orden de inglaterra de quedarse
en casa se amplió para aplicarse a 24
millones de personas ésta se produce
después de confirmar que una nueva cepa
de coronavirus más contagiosa circula
sin control por el país
la nueva variante ha llevado a más de 50
países a imponer restricciones de viaje
a reino unido pero esto no ha impedido
que haya nuevos casos en otros estados
europeos